CAN’T MISS TONIGHT BUT FIRST,
READING, WRITING AND RADICALISM.
THAT IS THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT’S
"ANGLE."
NOW LAST NIGHT, I EXPLAINED THE
DEMOCRATS SO OBSESSED WITH
BEATING TRUMP IN NOVEMBER,
WORKING OVERTIME TO KEEP
AMERICANS, EVEN CHILDREN
MISERABLE.
NOW CASE IN POINT, NEXT ORDER
WASHINGTON, D.C., THE
FAIRFAX COUNTY PUBLIC SCHOOLS
ANNOUNCED CHILDREN WERE NOT BE
PERMITTED TO RETURN TO SCHOOL
FIVE DAYS A WEEK AS NORMAL.
ONLY PROVIDING A TWO DAY A WEEK
OR AN ALL ONLINE OPTION.
PARENTS AND STUDENTS ARE RIGHTLY
OUTRAGED.
NEW YORK CITY HAS ANNOUNCED IT
IS GOING TO ADOPT A SIMILAR PLAN
FOR THE FALL LEAVING ALL THE
WORKING PARENTS THERE IN A
COMPLETE MIND AND KIDS, OF
COURSE, LEFT WONDERING IF LIFE
WILL EVER BE THE SAME FOR THEM
AGAIN.
NOW HAVING PARENTS STRESS AND
CONFUSION, GOVERNOR CUOMO SAID
TODAY HE MAY NOT LET SCHOOLS
REOPEN AT ALL.
NOW, DEMOCRATS, THE TEACHERS
UNION ARE PUTTING THEIR OWN
POLITICAL INTEREST FIRST AND
EDUCATION SECRETARY
BETSY DeVOS MUST HAVE WATCHED
THE SHOW LAST NIGHT BECAUSE SHE
NAILED THEM ON IT TODAY.
>> THERE ARE SOME CREATING FALSE
PARADIGMS FOR THE FALL.
HERE RIGHT IN OUR NEIGHBORHOOD
TO COME AT THE D.C. AREA,
FAIRFAX COUNTY, WHICH IS ONE OF
THE MOST WELL-FUNDED -- I WOULD
IT AN ELITE PUBLIC SCHOOL IN
AMERICA -- OFFERED FAMILIES A
SO-CALLED CHOICE FOR THIS FALL.
EITHER ZERO DAYS IN SCHOOL FOR
THEIR STUDENTS WORK TWO DAYS.
IT WOULD FAIL AMERICANS STUDENTS
AND IT WOULD FAIL TAXPAYERS.
>> Laura: AND GUESS WHAT,
INGRAM DOME XP 30 GETS RESULTS.
AFTER WE HIGHLIGHTED THE
FAIRFAX COUNTY DISASTER, THE
DISTRICT ANNOUNCED LATER THIS
AFTERNOON IT IS CONSIDERING
MANDATING JUST 3 FEET OF SOCIAL
DISTANCING BETWEEN THE KIDS,
MEANING THAT MORE KIDS COULD
POTENTIALLY GO TO SCHOOL IN
PERSON.
IT IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION, BUT IT IS STILL FAR
FROM WHAT THE SCIENCE IS TELLING
US.
>> WE KNOW MORTALITY RATE AND
UNDER 25 IS LESS THAN .1%.
WE HAVE NO EVIDENCE THAT THERE
IS SIGNIFICANT MORTALITY IN
CHILDREN WITH THE OUT COMING
EXISTING DISEASES.
>> Laura: JOE BIDEN’S IGNORES
THE DATA THAT SHOW THAT THE
SHUTDOWNS HAVEN’T AND DO NOT
WORK.
INSTEAD, THEY OPT FOR STRESSING
AMERICA WITH FEAR AND PANIC IN
HOPES TO HURT THE ECONOMY ENOUGH
TO HURT DONALD TRUMP ON ELECTION
DAY.
NOW COME UP COURSE, THEY DON’T
GIVE A DAMN AND A PROCESS
CHILDREN AND OUR FAMILIES WILL
BE COLLATERAL DAMAGE.
>> A LOT OF OUR KIDS ARE
HURTING.
THEY ARE STRUGGLING WITH
LONELINESS, SOCIAL ISOLATION.
THE AMERICAN ACADEMY OF
PEDIATRICS SPOKE ABOUT IT.
A VERY FORCEFUL STATEMENT FROM
PEDIATRICIANS ACROSS THE COUNTRY
TO GET KIDS BACK IN SCHOOL.
>> Laura: IF WALK DOWN ENDS
FOR JOE, FAIRFAX AND SCHOOL PLAN
TO BECOME THE NORM FOR THE REST
OF THE COUNTRY.
PARENTS ALREADY TOTALLY STRESSED
OUT BY ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY ARE
GOING TO BE PUSHED TO THE EDGE.
I’VE HEARD FROM THEM.
IT IS A HOUSE OF CARDS.
AND IT GETS WORSE.
BIDEN SUPPORTING EDGE OF CRAFTS
EAGER TO WORK LESS BUT NOT
DR. NATE MOORE.
WHAT AM I TALKING ABOUT?
"BLACK LIVES MATTER" ZEALOUS
OUTSIDE INFLUENCE LIKE
FAIRFAX COUNTY AND THEIR GOAL IS
TO TURN YOUR KIDS AND TWO
HARD-CORE ACTIVISTS BY REMAKING
EDUCATION FROM TOP TO BOTTOM.
YOU DON’T BELIEVE ME?
HERE IS VIDEO, OUR NEXT GUEST
SHOP FROM A PUBLIC WORKS SESSION
OF FAIRFAX SCHOOL LEADERS.
>> WE WANT TO TALK ABOUT ALL THE
OTHER THINGS THAT OPPONENTS WILL
CREATE FOR THE SCHOOL SYSTEM.
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT IT
SYSTEMICALLY.
>> WE HAVE CREATED OFFICER
POSITIONS AND WE’VE DONE GOOD
WORK IN THIS, BUT WE ARE A LONG
WAYS AWAY FROM IT.
>> IT WILL BE A MEANINGFUL
CHALLENGE TO SYSTEMIC RACISM.
I BELIEVE WE MUST BE HONEST
ABOUT OUR POLICIES AND
INTERACTION.
>> Laura: I LOVE HOW THEY ARE
READING EVERYTHING, BY THE WAY,
THE TEACHERS AND EDUCATORS.
COULDN’T THEY JUST ME?
WHEN YOU WATCH THAT, YOU IMAGINE
THE WORST OF HOWARD’S END PLATES
MAY BE AT THE 1619 PROJECT AND
YOU GET THE PICTURE.
EVERY SUBJECT, EVERY
EXTRACURRICULAR ACTIVITY WILL BE
PERVERTED TO TURN YOUR KIDS INTO
MANY ILHAN OMAR’S.
THEY WILL LEARN CAPITALISM IS
RACIST.
HISTORY IS RACIST, LITERATURE
MOST OF THAT IS RACIST,
PATRIOTIC SONGS, RACIST AND THE
DECLARATION AND THE
CONSTITUTION, OF COURSE, THEY
ARE RACIST.
ARE YOU SENSING A THEME HERE?
SAY GOODBYE TO THE THREE THAT
ARE ORS READING, WRITING AND
ARITHMETIC AND THE 3CS CANCEL
CULTURE AND COMMUNITY
ORGANIZING.
WHAT ABOUT TEACHERS OR
ADMINISTRATORS?
THOSE PEOPLE THAT DON’T AGREE
WITH US AND EITHER TECHNICALLY
OR EXPLICITLY RESIST.
THEY WILL BE DRIVEN OUT.
MAYBE THEY WILL BE FOUND GUILTY
AND NEWLY FORMED RACE TRIBUNALS
WITH SOME STUDENTS AND COLLEGES.
NOW WHEN YOU THINK YOU ARE TOO
BUSY AND I UNDERSTAND YOU GET
ACTIVE IN YOUR LOCAL SCHOOL
BOARD DECISION MAKING, THINK
ABOUT LOSING YOUR CHILD TO THE
SORT OF WHACKED OUT THINKING
THAT PARENTS AND ALUMNI HAVE
ALLOWED TO DOMINATE COLLEGE
CAMPUSES.
>> BY THE WAY, I HOPE YOU
REALIZE THAT DOES NOT MAKE YOU A
RACIST.
[APPLAUSE]
IN FACT, YOUR PERSONAL
OBJECTIFIED AND CRITICIZED BY
SOMEONE LIKE ME.
AND WHITE WASHED BLACKNESS.
YOU ARE SAYING THAT IS OKAY OR
THAT IS TRENDY.
WELL, I AM NOT YOUR [BLEEP]
TREND.
>> Laura: SHE’S TALKING ABOUT
PEOPLE LIKE US OF MIXED RACE
CHILDREN THAT THEY ARE NOT
RACIST, IN FACT, THEY ARE MORE
RACIST.
YOU SHOULDN’T WANT THE PEOPLE
WHO TAUGHT THAT YOUNG WOMAN
WITHIN 10 FEET OF YOUR CHILD’S
CLASSROOM OR EVEN LECTURING THEM
ONLINE FOR THAT MATTER.
SO THE ADULTS IN FAIRFAX COUNTY
PLOWED THEMSELVES FOR A NAME
CHANGE OF THEIR SCHOOL, THE
HIGH SCHOOL.
TOTAL PANDERING.
MEANWHILE THEY CLOSE THEIR
CLASSROOMS THREE DAYS A WEEK,
HURTING THE MINORITY KIDS THEY
SUPPOSEDLY CARES MUCH ABOUT.
>> THE MOTION BEFORE US IS TO
PROCEED WITH THE NAME CHANGE FOR
ROBERT E. LEE HIGH SCHOOL.
THAT IS UNANIMOUS, THE MOTION
CARRIES.
[APPLAUSE]
>> I, THE SUPERINTENDENT COME TO
BRING YOU MY RECOMMENDATIONS FOR
A POSSIBLE NEW NAME FOR LEE
HIGH SCHOOL.
THE FIRST IS JOHN LEWIS, THE
NEXT NAME BARACK OBAMA, THE NEXT
NAME I HAVE TO SHARE WITH THE
BOARD IS SHOP AS.
>> I WANT TO SHARE WITH YOU MY
SHOP AS A STUFFED ANIMAL DOG I
HAVE.
>> Laura: THAT DOLL HAS MORE
BRAINPOWER THAN THE GROWN WOMAN
HOLDING IT.
AND SHE IS CLOSE IN ANY WAY TO
MAKING EDUCATION DON’T MAKE
DECISIONS ABOUT EDUCATION?
OUR SCHOOL UNDER THE GUISE OF
RACIAL AWARENESS WILL BE
PRESSURED TO THESE TYPES OF
RADICALS, PRESSURE TO BOW TO
THEM.
PEOPLE WHO WOULD RATHER SIT AT
HOME AND ONLINE PROPAGANDA
SESSIONS THAN ACT LIKE THE
ESSENTIAL WORKERS THAT THEY ARE,
WHETHER ACTUAL CLASSROOMS
INTERACTING WITH ACTUAL KIDS,
TEACHING THEM ACTUAL ESSENTIALS.
IN PERSON.
AND OF COURSE, THESE WILL BE
PRECISELY THE PEOPLE YOU CAN
EXPECT TO POPULATE A JOE BIDEN
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION BECAUSE
BIDEN, HE WILL ALWAYS CATER TO
THE LEFTIST UNION BAYS.
>> THIS WILL BE A TEACHER OR
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION.
IT WILL NOT COME FROM THE TOP OF
THE TEACHERS UP.
YOU KNOW, I DON’T JUST HAVE A
PARTNER IN THE WHITE HOUSE.
>> Laura: THAT IS SCARY.
IS THIS WHAT AMERICAN PARENTS
REALLY WANT, A PRESIDENT WHO
WILL PRESIDE OVER THE TOTAL
EROSION OF OUR SCHOOLS?
A TOTAL APPLICATION TO THE
TEACHERS UNION WHOSE FIRST
LOYALTY ISN’T JUST TO STUDENTS,
BUT TO THEIR OWN MEMBERSHIP AND
ULTIMATELY, OF COURSE, THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY?
WE CAN MAKE A DIFFERENT CHOICE.
LET’S AFFORD A PRESIDENT AND
SECRETARY OF EDUCATION WHO ARE
OUT THERE FIGHTING FOR PARENTS
AND KIDS.
LET’S TAKE BACK CONTROL OF FIRE
SCHOOLS AND TRAIN CHILDREN WHO
LOVE HISTORY, ITS ECONOMY AND
ITS POLITICAL SYSTEM.
LET’S WIN THIS ELECTION AND
TEACH THE LEFT THE MOST
IMPORTANT OF ALL, THAT THIS
COUNTRY BELONGS TO ALL OF THE
PEOPLE, NOT TO A SMALL NUMBER OF
ANTI-AMERICAN RADICALS.
NOW, IF WE CHOOSE THAT, WE WON’T
FAIL OUR KIDS.